[Music]
you mentioned car insurance I mean where
does health insurance follow this
because hello germs right now is making
everyone completely in sight no matter
what side you're on and everyone is
crazy about this so what is then the
answer for health insurance in your view
right well I guess that's why the last
question I'll ask you for the interview
so you know health insurance so you know
I like I have the extreme view that
there's no reason for government to be
involved in this area at all and what's
very striking is that while most
economists officially sale would
disagree but when you win it one I've
actually got an argue with them usually
when they argue for regulation they're
arguing for regulations to fix other
regulations and when I say well what if
we just didn't have the first
regulations or try to fix then the
reaction is kind of like well I never
really thought about it that much so you
know just for example the only I like
the whole idea of Obamacare is that all
right well first we're gonna have a
regulation saying that you can't turn
people down for insurance and secondly
we're gonna have a regulation saying
that you can't charge them higher prices
and then people normally realize wait a
second your system like that then a lot
of people just wait around until they're
sick and so then we're gonna require
people to buy insurance to avoid the
problems created by the first two
regulations and then we're gonna then
there's people too poor to afford it so
then we're gonna subsidize those people
to deal with the other three regulations
all right so you know my view is there's
really no reason why you couldn't have
scrapped all the regulations just said
look here's or ascended by insurance if
you wait until you're sick you won't be
able to afford it but then what do you
do for those people so I guess I get
that but right isn't then what what
happens as a result of that is that X
amount of people and it's gonna be a lot
of people simply will not do it because
they'd rather spend their money
elsewhere and hope that they'll be
healthy or they'll just get a broken leg
playing basketball or something else or
whatever and then we still end up paying
for them right don't I rest of it
automatically end up paying for them not
automatically again if you get rid of
all those regulations then then once the
other service and then you have to rely
on charity and okay so like jail court
of course charity includes family
includes everybody else yeah that might
want to help you but that you know the
say well that's terrible I wouldn't want
have to deal with that yes that's why
you buy insurance in advance is because
you don't want to be put in that
position right so yeah yeah of course
then you start like star thinking about
the horrible cases like what about a
child born to responsible parents and
then a child has a lifelong congenital
disease I say that's the kind of thing
that charities are going to be very well
equipped to handle they're probably not
going to be so equipped to handle
someone who's 25 and was earning a
middle-class income it didn't feel like
buying insurance and then they come down
with a horrible problem those are ones
where I think you're likely to be very
low in priority and it's more like
you're an adult and it was your
responsibility take care of yourself but
sort of in the backgrounds is the issue
of like how can you just be so callous
as to say if you went and did something
really dumb that it's just your own
tough luck and yes I have this old blog
post called tough luck right so you know
what every political philosophy
ultimately says tough luck to people
it's just a question of where they draw
the line so you know there's the right
well what if there's a conservative
conservative government power and they
can script my son any sent to another
country and you get any dies what
happens then and of course the
conservative answer is ultimately well
tough luck that's the system like I like
in my system you can be conscripted if I
know where you don't want to and
sometimes when that happens you get put
into a lethal area and you die and like
well my life has been ruined and what're
you gonna do about it
nothing oh and they'll give you a plaque
all right yeah so or similar you know
like you're similarly like you like you
you like even someone who is the firmest
supporter in the world of socialized
medicine so what if a person goes and
cuts off their own legs and then and
then whenever you go and send someone
help them they throw things at them what
are you gonna do then well then I guess
tough luck all right and that person is
this gonna be alone in me suffering
because they wouldn't go along with the
system yeah all right so Steven that
every single philosophy ultimately says
tough luck I don't see why people who
believe in the free market should feel
especially embarrassed to say weigh on
my system this is where we draw the line
and if you have failed to do all of
these things then then it's here then
it's your problem because there is no
perfect system based yes there's no
perfect system and and again like would
it be a perfect system if someone could
be completely responsible hundred times
in a row and would still get treated
like everybody else
they've done any studies that you know
of where they've shown where in cases
that the government pulls back that
charity does take care of this stuff so
that in the case which i think is a
legitimate like philosophically I fully
get what you're saying there that if we
just pulled back a little bit that
people would give more is there evidence
of that because oh well so it's almost
all the evidence is the other way around
where it's there used to be private
charity and then government started
doing it and then people measure what
happened to the charity that was
involved off so there's no this is
called crowding out there's a whole
field economic to charity where they
study this and this is a totally
standard result that there are many
areas that private charity used to take
care of like helping out the poor demand
now and as government expanded its role
the role of private charities shrank
down and eventually eventually private
charity moved into other areas the
government wasn't doing very much about
yeah so yeah so you like in the 30s so
well you like you don't still Excel like
really oh so the 30s is sort of when
there was a big transition because there
were many private organization is there
things called fraternal clubs and
organizations that were private clubs
that did a lot of things that the modern
welfare state does so if you lost your
job that either take care of you if
there were sickness they'd go and take
care of you the 30s was such a
protracted depression depression that
finding that the part that partly
started breaking down then but again a
lot of it was government to us took over
and once government took over there
really wasn't much point to belong to
the organizations anymore except to go
and put on funny hats and then once a
month yeah but you know like a lot a lot
of these like groups they like you
remember your grandfather being part of
like the Elks or the Odd Fellows these
actually provided these welfare state
functions privately in the past so do
you think that something like you know
government funded planned Parenthood
which I'm sure regardless of your
feelings on abortion I'm sure you're not
for the government funding that I can
accept that part so for myself I'm
pro-choice but when I see all these
people talking about public funding of
all these things it does seem to me that
if the government stopped funding these
things not made it illegal now that
abortion is oh but stop funding that
this seems like the case where so many
people are so passionate about all these
people in Hollywood who are constantly
tweeting about this and scream right but
they wouldn't start funding these things
so is that a great example I think I
think I think it is a great example I
mean really here
here's the main thing that is troubling
about the economics charity is there's a
bunch of cause to the people that they
care about and those I'm not worried
about those there's gonna be plenty of
money for them there's a bunch of other
terrible things happening the world that
private charity manifestly of incessant
solved it hasn't gone and solved
international refugee problems and it's
doing something but they're still
terrible things going on isn't solved
hunger in other countries and the thing
is that these are these are problems
that taxpayers don't care much about and
that charitable gamers don't care very
much about so not you so again like you
know Bill Gates cares and you know he's
he's making a single handily making a
noticeable dent in the problem but I
mean so you know sort of like the issues
that people are really concerned about
the ones that have a lot of support for
taxpayers to do something about it about
them are also very plausibly ones where
private donors would care a lot as well
yeah is there any situation where you
think regulation is necessary is there
you know someone will I'm sure someone
watching this is gonna comment well what
about there the rivers they're gonna
pollute all the rivers or anything is
there any instance where you see it as
yeah I mean what I would say is I don't
know I was so there you know the
audience so there's a lot of areas where
given the given given the current set up
it's very hard to see how like how like
how either either a for-profit or even a
charitable response to it
again the question in my mind is always
if we imagine going and privatizing
things the government ago the government
government now does then what's left and
then what's left the charity can't
handle so I mean that any of that's we
don't like you know to me like you know
part of being an intercom capitalist is
least saying well let's privatize and
see before saying there's no way the
private action are going to handle this
problem let's go and take a take a look
and of course all the private solutions
may take a while to emerge but then
again like you know like there are many
problems the government has dealt with
very poorly so far so I don't think it's
fair to say after a year you know
private sector doesn't solve this yet so
therefore clearly governments s theory
will maybe give it some more time but
even like the more the ones that I think
are the clearest cases are you know air
pollution so that's one where it's very
hard to exactly see how the private like
how for profits of health for profit
sector would handle it it's one where
because air pollution moves across their
boobs like they're like you could you're
not walking around in a bubble I get
it's one where well again you suppose
the
government didn't do anything about it
but there's private area involved right
private charity to go and say subsidize
lower lower polluting technologies or
offer prizes for lower polluting
technologies and then give away the
patent so that the new technologies are
really cheap again so like us to like
like how well that would work I honest I
honestly we have to say it's so far from
where we are I don't know but I think we
I think we should give it a try
yeah so most people watching us know
that I'm a limited government guy I
believe in states rights I would always
rather be governed by the mayor and my
local representative than federally
governed by the mayor of Los Angeles Wow
all right so you know he's a little he
lives a little closer to me than the
people in DC let's put it that way
regardless of my feelings of the mayor
of Los Angeles but generally speaking I
want
I believe in local local control so are
there instances where local control has
done this better like is there is there
a noun you can point to or is there a
state maybe that's doing some of this a
little bit better let's see so given
that there's so many states and so many
localities I'm sure that there are yeah
I don't know off the top of the head
which which one which ones they are
but yeah so like is that partly just
because yes the feds now have so much
control over everything it's hard for
States to do they there is but again
blight like you know so like states do
manage Norma's amount I'd say the main
issue actually is just that the federal
government provides so much of the money
for for state governments that a lot of
the competitive pressure that you think
would be operating is has really been
neutered by the fact that states are
just receive a bag of money from the
federal government for certain purposes
and if they aren't allowed to go and use
it for other purposes and so they have
very low incentive to try to figure out
a way of saving taxpayers taxpayers
money on it or and often the money of
course comes a lot of strings attached
if you don't want the strings and you
have to get back all the money so very
few places want to do that yeah so what
would you do in a case when you know
when we hear about federal money being
used and everyone says okay it's right
so like for example like you know
hurricane sandy hits Jersey the the
Jersey Shore is destroyed and then Obama
that was probably hundreds of millions
of dollars I don't know top of my head
or or Hurricane Katrina in New Orleans
do you again this would be the same
thing I think I mean if so like probably
have private insurance there's no reason
that you
have private disaster insurance and of
course there is a lot of private jets or
insurance sold normally the feds get in
where there's an area so high risk that
the insurance will be really expensive
and people with beach homes don't feel
like having to pay for it and so either
the feds take care of it or they
subsidize it and again like you know so
we especially to me the idea that
someone with a beach house to get some
subsidized insurance because it's high
it's a high disaster area around
I like the disaster I'm always baffled
by that you look they're living in a
beach house yeah well I can't they like
why can't a person in a beach house be
expected to buy their own insurance well
a lot of them do have insurance but
that's a full market price for the
insurance so ultimately it's like that
would would people then be forced to
move from a place like normally oh so
either you go well yours that you
wouldn't really be forced to move and
tell the value of your home false enough
yeah yes but eventually IDs so select
out yeah yeah so so we like realize like
really what would happen given that
beach homes normally your very valuable
is that those homes would just be worth
less yeah because people realize if I
move into this home I'm going to buy
some really expensive insurance so that
doesn't sound very good so ultimately
the real like you know like subsidizing
disaster insurance is a subsidy to
people who develop in hi and I'm
disaster prone areas right people own
land in those areas are ultimately the
people who really benefit from it
because raises the value of that real
estate I guess it I've never really
thought about it in most specific terms
but you know I Drive by Malibu here
which is gorgeous and all these rich
people living on these cliffs right on
the water and at the end of the day if
something horrible happened which of
course would mean yes the government
would be then giving money to people be
chose to live there and iris thing
because their insurance didn't go above
and beyond whatever the necessary of
government requirements yeah so I mean
my family lives in this area so they're
in labor so a couple miles from the
Northridge earthquake and back in 1994
and I know relatives who were just
calling up FEMA and saying and give me
money give me money and look they got
money like you know it didn't matter
like how rich you are or like we're what
you had done or whether you had built
your home safely it's like like the you
know like just the squeaky wheel got the
grease really all you do is pick up a
phone and so is that the real problem
with all of this that ultimately by
doing all of this regulation
you punish people who do the right thing
sure sure in a case like this there's
someone who built their house earthquake
safe Bob all invested their own money in
all of that maybe had some damage maybe
didn't Northridge was a massive
earthquake yeah but then they're getting
scooped they're not getting government
money because they did the right thing
and put their own money in it yeah so
you know absolutely so it's not you know
it's not fair it's not just I mean
economists would also point out it's a
it's highly inefficient because you're
giving people incentives to not do the
right things the other thing you know
the end the final point that's worth
making is so like I'm the kind of person
who defends radical or extreme views but
I never want to alienate people who are
a little bit less radical a little bit
less extreme in all these cases like you
know I'm still saying look if you if
you're very concerned about small
minority of very poor people who really
couldn't afford insurance during this
time then aren't fine have a government
program that that subsidizes a provides
insurance for you know orphaned children
for people for 40 or for kids who have
terrible diseases for people who are the
old very poor but happen to happen to be
struck by disaster you know you could
have a program that costs 5% as much as
what we're currently create doing we
could get rid of 95% without really
bumping into any of the complaints that
enroll people have no saying like well
what if what about what about the poor
what about kids what about people with
their responsible parents and still you
could go 95 percent of the way to the
libertarian policy and again you sold me
like I'm the kind of person who says
what about the last 5% but I don't want
to go and lose people lose people
because we're willing to go the first 95
so it's we're saying look with health
insurance all right well maybe we'll see
a government could still subsidize it
for you know for kids of poor parents
for people that are that were born with
it with a will with a get with a
terrible congenital disease like it just
make a few exceptions and then stop
making the exceptions yeah so you like
this small area this is where it's so
terrible government's gonna to pay for
it out of taxpayer money everyone else
though sink or swim usually like you're
an adult you should take care of
yourself yeah you must bang your head on
the wall every time people in public
demand that the government throw more
money at things right cuz we this is
like it's always the easy answer and
only see it feels right to people throw
money at education throw more money and
especially in the throw away the
throwing is a great image because it
suggests a lack of accuracy lack of it
lack of interest in actually targeting
any specific problem so I mean I've just
wrapped up a book on education called
the case against education where I argue
for defunding education right so yes I
yell like isn't that bad for you well
yeah it would be bad for me people
listen but still my conscience says this
is the right thing to do okay so sell me
on that I come from I went to a public
elementary school public junior high
public high school I went to State
University of New York at Binghamton
which was hugely subsidized by the
government I think it was around $9,000
a year and I got a great education mmm
why am i CEO so I you know I went to
public schools right in this
neighborhood actually but you know say
like yeah like like the heart of my case
is something called the signaling model
of Education so this this is a fancy
term for a common-sense idea just says
that a lot of the reason why education
pays is not that it's teaching useful
job skills but rather you're jumping
through hoops to show off for employers
all right so you know just think about
all the classes that you ever had to
take and then how few of them are
actually relevant to it to the job that
you do you actually probably have a job
where you do use more of what more of
what you study you know that's a
political sense yes yes but the thinking
thing but just think about all the
classes that were required where you
would not where you would not have been
allowed to graduate without going
through all of them so I mean I always
have this example imagine you're like
one Aristotle class short of college
graduation and yet you want to finish
that class why because you're gonna use
the Mickey Maki and ethics and on the
job probably not rather because you want
that diploma and employers are like many
employers will just throw your
application right in the trash unless
you have the diploma but do you lose
something doing it your way because of
just a certain breadth of knowledge now
I'm not saying that every class should
be mandated and if all right they stick
you in things yes that shouldn't be
necessary but just that in terms of
college specifically but that's where
you should get a broad sense of
knowledge would that be at risk then
well here's the thing it's not at risk
because almost no one gets it now that's
there so that is our truth is that you
just go and look at what graduates of
the current system know it is next to
nothing right so there have been
great nationally representative surveys
of what American adults know about
government about history about economics
and the answer is they know next nothing
so if we were to defend the system
saying that people need breadth of
knowledge well it's not a defense of the
current system because they've had this
current system it's not giving it to
them
the the way that I like to think about
it is that typical American college
graduate is lucky to maybe answer half
of the most basic questions you can
imagine on civics yeah now you might say
well they then they that was still worth
why I always say it's not worthwhile
because what do you call someone who
knows half their letters what do you
call someone who knows half the letters
reading it letters you are illiterate
you're not a half literate if you don't
have your letters yeah we're illiterate
because you cannot read yeah similarly
say if you know half the basic facts
about about US history or about American
government you don't know half what you
need to know you just don't know it at
all if you don't have a clue if you
think there are one and a half branches
of government you just don't have a clue
about what's going on
yeah and that's where the current system
is given us so when people say like
wouldn't this be a disaster or say well
you might say the current system is
disaster but what I'm proposing wouldn't
be worse now there's always the question
well but why not go and redouble our
efforts so that people really do learn
the stuff anything I'd say is like
you've the resources that it would take
or so vast in fact like I don't know of
any actual sign that oh that it could be
done and I also I do have a way cheaper
alternative to the current system for
actually getting people to learn this
stuff so you know like this is this is
one of my most performance proposals so
it doesn't well it doesn't involve
government money but it still I'd say a
way better use of the government money
than what we're doing right now okay so
here's the proposal every year there is
a government test of your knowledge of
civics and if you get a good score you
get some money the end all right now
what's the point of this well two points
first of all it gives people an
incentive to actually learn the material
by oh in whatever means actually works
best yeah so they learn and you get
something yes and ruble yes yes so like
you know you could learn it on the
internet you could just read a book you
could learn it in school like any
possible method of learning the material
is equally rewarded so it doesn't go and
throw money to
high school civics teachers who have
manifestly failed to I failed to
actually generate a knowledgeable public
instead it just opens it up to say
there's a war for knowing stuff however
you learn it is fine but the other
reason why you do it every year is
because there's enormous evidence in
educational psychology that people
generally forget what they learn very
quickly so on test day actually I
believe that most of the students in the
civics class probably actually kind of
knew their stuff but what's what
psychologists call fade-out is so
enormous just the way like in one year
out the next if you don't keep testing
and you don't keep using it you lose it
so if you have a test every year this
would actually lead to retention of
knowledge over time where people would
not immediately forget the material as
soon as they learn it's like wow I need
to know what next year and the year
after that every year I can get another
hundred bucks off of showing that I know
myself so and there's no you don't
there's a way to privatize that then um
so you can do a charity I mean like this
is legal and no charity has done it so
I'm not too optimistic about it
happening but yeah like if some if some
donor right now is interested in doing
this this would be great but anyway this
would be so much cheaper then high that
then all the high school social sciences
classes that we offer right now whatever
you bros don't ask people often start
freaking out who's gonna write the test
and I say well look right now a key part
of civics is knowing the answers the
teacher wants to hear so like even you
like as long as you know that there's a
certain bias on the on the official
civics test you just vacate and like in
order to do well in it you still have to
learn a bunch of stuff so you know I
mean I in so many college classes where
I disagreed with the professor I still
learn I learned what the answers they
wanted to hear but I also learned the
material the same time and like there's
no reason why you couldn't do that do it
apply the same thing I mean so I don't
see that it's really such a deciding on
such a terrible deal yeah I'd love to
see the fade-out rate for kids the day
after the SATs because I remember
studying for that thing and got United
with it with a group of friends but I
remember thinking man when I'm done with
this thing I am going to let go all this
and I had taken the test probably a week
later I probably got a half this or
something I mean this is some of the
most interesting research in psychology
so there's a lot of research on fade-out
in school where you go and you teach the
kids something and then you go and
measure it one or two years later in
school
but the really scare the really scary
fade out is from school to adulthood
because the kids in school at least they
kind of know I'm gonna have to learn
this again I make it test is on again
once you finally graduate that's it
that's the end yeah so there's a
fantastic study of retention of higher
mathematics throughout life and it's
like algebra and geometry you're like
with it within a couple decades most
people took those classes just know
we're back to where they were before
they even actually started the classes
the only people remember their algebra
geometry or people go all the way up to
calculus go all the way to go then you
go and retain algebra and geometry for
the rest of your life but you have to go
way beyond a subject to actually retain
the Bell retain the basics mm-hmm any of
this all fits with what you like so like
you'll use it or lose it or you know
Tiger mom maybe Chu has a great slogan
like every day every day every day you
don't practice this day you get worse so
you this does go with well so why bother
teaching people things they're just
gonna forget anyway yeah so I mean this
this is part of my critique of like like
what's wrong with throwing so much money
at you know education you gonna say Oh
get like now of course none of this
denies that schools do teach some useful
material but again on my view is all
right again so like for the useful
material like you like most people can
pay for it probably most people's
parents can pay for it and then if
there's going to be any role for
government let it be for the small
minority kids whose parents are not able
to take care of them or share --'tis not
taking care of them and then for just
that last liver of people let you know
they like if there's gonna be a role for
government let it be that so don't throw
money at a problem there's gonna be
money let it be narrowly targeted to
give to be mindful that you are taking
money from taxpayers without their
consent and a minimum you owe them a
responsibility to spend the money well I
think that seems like a really basic
thing I think we've given up that yeah
that minimum a long time yeah but you
know like you know so it's one thing to
say look this is so important that we're
gonna that were that you have to pay
whether you like it or not too bad but
then go and spend that money he lessly
that seems like it's real like a true
really like honestly like there seems
like a like a true human rights abuse to
take someone for money at gunpoint and
then just blow it like without saying
well maybe this will do something who
knows yeah maybe if that's your attitude
you shouldn't have taken my money
like maybe you should have asked me but
you shouldn't have made me if that's all
you've got
you